Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
¿Cómo es que Airbnb y Uber
pudieron ser líderes de sus industrias
sin tener un auto
ni un departamento en su poder?
Lo hicieron creando confianza entre la gente.
Y si nos ponemos a pensar,
muchas de las empresas más importantes
de nuestros días se basan en eso.
Se basan en construir economías colaborativas
usando la reputación de las personas.
Pero hay un problema que es que
ellos se quedan con nuestra información.
Pero eso va a cambiar
porque hace unos diez años,
de la mano de bitcoin,
nació el primer registro,
el primer libro inhackeable,
en el cual no solamente podemos
registrar transferencias de dinero
sino que podemos registrar todas
las cosas que hacemos en nuestra vida.
Igual que con las calificaciones de Uber
pero con la diferencia de que
nosotros estamos en control.
Con ese registro vamos a poder construir
nuestra vida blockchain.
Y con esa vida blockchain
vamos a poder interactuar
con cualquier persona del planeta,
vamos a poder construir
nuestras propias economías colaborativas,
y va a ser el inicio del fin de las fronteras.
Va a dar nacimiento
a una nación realmente global;
a una nación humana,
así que los invito a volver a reunirnos
y poder compartir nuestra vida blockchain,
una vida sin fronteras, sin límites
y con muchas oportunidades.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)